- [Lorenzo] Mental health
in the Black community
has been a problem for decades.
A lot of that plays into the
stigma about mental health
and the reason why people are not going
to get the help that's necessary.
Barbershops are a safe place
for young men of color.
Barbers are our only people in our lives
that we allow to get close
proximity with a razor.
We realize the barber become our friends,
and that's really important
because I could've used
that same space and work with barbers
to talk about our mental health.
(gentle piano music)
(gentle string music)
My name is Lorenzo Lewis,
and I am the founder and
CEO of The Confess Project.
The Confess Project is a
national grassroots movement
that is geared around building a dialogue
of mental health for young men of color.
I had a lot of problems as a young person.
My mother was incarcerated when
I was born into this world,
and with losing my dad at the age of 10,
I didn't know how to deal with it.
I would go to this beauty
salon everyday after school,
and there was a barber there,
and I never forget a lot of the nurturing
and care that I got from him
really empowered me to wanna do better,
really wanted to empower
me to do good in school.
I realized that I'm not
the only one struggling.
Suicide is the third
leading cause of death
for young men of color
between the ages of 18 and 24.
And a lot of this plays into communities
where there are a lot of
violence and toxic masculinity.
So the barbershop was a perfect place
to start The Confess Project.
I walk into a barbershop and ask them
if I can have a moment of their time,
and then that moment turns
in an educational session.
Thank you all for being here today.
I think the most important part
of why I really came here today,
is to really so that I exhibit to you all
how we can break through our pain,
and how to part with
that being our purpose.
Our goal is to not train barbers
to be mental health experts
but to train them to be
mental health advocates.
We're training them with the skills
of active listening,
communication, validation,
to not be judgemental, to
be sensitive with language
so that their clients
can be able to open up
and possibly go and get some help
and treatment that may be necessary.
- I've always been feeling
in a depressed state
and I never knew why.
I still don't know why.
- To be completely honest,
it was the first time I've
ever heard a black man talk
about his struggles with mental health
or his emotions with
feeling like he's low,
feeling like he's in that
hole that he can't get out of.
And that's a feeling that
I felt before growing up.
It's a feeling that I felt often,
and it's a feeling that I was feeling
in that time that I came to here.
- I thought it was very powerful,
seeing black men coming together,
hugging and sharing that
valuable moment together.
And you could see it in their eyes
and in their emotion.
(crowd applauding)
(calm instrumental music)
- Since starting The Confess Project,
we have now expanded to nine U.S. cities
across the southern and mid-west region.
It's really important to
keep that momentum going,
and we realize that we still
have a lot of work to do.
And it's one of those things
where we have to create leaders
and build a generation of leaders,
so that they can be
sustained and also go out
and help many more community members
that we may not reach.
What I specifically love about my job is
that I get to work with that side of me
that I wasn't able to
get that same help with
and help young men of
color to really thrive
and to really become the
best version of who they are.
(gentle string music)
(gentle ringing)